hey everyone so I've got a book coming
out later this month you can check it
out or pre-order it in the description
below welcome to another cold fusion
video nanobots you may have seen them
depicted in movies like big hero 6 but
recently they're becoming a reality
although not in the form that you'll
expect in this video we'll take a look
at what they are and the promise that
they hold in the context of
biotechnology and some of the latest
research happening around the globe
[Music]
[Applause]
the research suggests and nanobots could
assist medical professionals in complex
tasks after passing through tiny spaces
in the human body
one of the biggest potential
applications is for extremely targeted
drug delivery to specific cells within
the body as well soon see this has
already been achieved scientists also
believe that none of us could be used to
reduce plaque and veins solve dietary
issues along with a whole slew of other
medical uses they'll be able to operate
in parts of the body where the blood
flow is slower such as capillaries in
the iron or fluids outside the
circulatory system such as ventricles of
the brain or urinary tract so all of you
have probably heard of CRISPR gene
editing although not directly related
crisperizer offshoot of the nanobot idea
CRISPR is actually an exploitation of a
natural molecular DNA function
scientists use a virus's natural ability
to cut and splice the DNA we want to
edit at will we've talked about CRISPR
DNA editing in the case of destroying
cancer in a previous video I'll leave it
in the description below so you can open
it in a new tab we'll take a closer look
at DNA nanobots in a second but first
let's delve into where this idea came
from in the first place it's older than
you might imagine the origin of nanobots
is commonly attributed to Richard
Fineman a scientist in the Manhattan
Project the man behind the theory of
quantum computers and a pivotal mind in
quantum physics fineman's solidified his
idea in his 1959 writing there's plenty
of room at the bottom in ered Richard
Feynman imagined a day where machines
could be miniaturized and huge amounts
of information could be encoded in
miniscule spaces paving the way for
disruptive technological developments
the technology would be so good that it
could quote swallow the surgeon as he
put it so what is nano
nanotechnology is the science
engineering and technology conducted at
the nano scale which is about 1 to 100
nanometers let's put that into a
perspective the ratio of the earth to
Marble is roughly the same ratio as a
meter to a nanometer a nanometer is a
million times smaller than the length of
an ant a strand of DNA is 2.5 nanometers
in diameter making them the perfect
candidate for a basis for nano robots
there's a couple of types of nanobots in
existence today but right now we'll
focus on those made from DNA and those
that are man-made so let's take a look
at the state-of-the-art researchers at
the University of San Diego develop nano
robots capable of cleaning toxins from
blood generated by harmful bacteria
these nano robots are about 25 times
smaller than the width of a human hair
and are made from a combination of
natural red blood cell and platelet
membranes and artificial Goldwire
they can be controlled by ultrasound
which eliminates the need for a battery
during propulsion while still
experimental early tests have proved
successful with nanobots Rita blood
containing three times less toxins and
bacteria than untreated blood
the scientists note that quote this is a
proof of concept platform for diverse
therapeutic and bio detoxification
applications and quite by using this
natural biomaterial membrane coating our
micro boat we can empower new
functionality new capability like
removal of petrol German dog swim from
the body researchers at the Arizona
State University and the National Center
for nanoscience and technology of the
Chinese Academy of scientists injected
nanobots made from a folded sheet of DNA
into the bloodstream of mice to perform
their study first scientists induced
aggressive tumor growth in the mice once
the tumor was growing the nanobots were
deployed to come to the rescue
each nano bond is made from a flat
rectangular DNA sheet 90 nano meters by
60 nanometers in size a key blood
clotting enzyme called
thrombin is attached to the surface
thrombin can pluck steam a blood flow by
cutting the blood vessels that feed tema
growth essentially leading to the tumors
death first an average of four thrombin
molecules were attached to the flat DNA
scaffold next the flat sheet was folded
in on itself like a sheet of paper into
a circle to make a hollow tube these
were then injected via IV into a mouse
the nanobots then traveled through the
blood stream homing in on the tumors the
key to programming a nanobot that only
attacks a cancer cell was to include a
special homing device that specifically
targets a protein that has made in large
amounts on the surface of tumor cells
the thing is this protein is not found
on the surface of healthy cells the
result is a DNA device that seeks our
team of blood vessels and is programmed
to release its blood clotting cargo
right into the heart of the tumor
killing it the nanobots worked quickly
congregating in large amounts to
surround the tumor just hours after
injection according to the scientists
this technology is a strategy that can
be used for many types of cancer since
all solid team of feeding blood vessels
are essentially the same so here were
the results three out of the eight mice
receiving the nanobot therapy showed
complete regression of the tumors the
median survival time more than doubled
extending from twenty point five days to
45 days healthy tissue was left
untouched and I think this is pretty
good for such an early trial they also
tried their system with lung cancer the
tumor tissue showed shrinkage after two
weeks of treatment professor huyang one
of the lead researchers weighs in with
his thoughts I think we're much closer
to real practical medical applications
of this technology combinations of
different rationally designed nano
robots carrying various agents may help
to accomplish the ultimate goal of
cancer research the eradication of solid
tumors in quote yan and his
collaborators are now actively pursuing
clinical partners to further develop
this technology
a nanobot device is roughly the size of
a red blood cell or smaller this is too
small to add elements like a motor
computer chip or camera so bioengineer
BOTS made from DNA are a common platform
for such medical tasks but as you'll see
next nanobots made from man-made
materials are possible and are currently
being used in research right now so here
we come to our featured story which was
the inspiration for this video not long
ago I was contacted from someone from
the Max Planck Institute in Stuttgart
Germany the team behind this next story
has done a world-first
this time using nano robot vehicles
instead of DNA these are the first nano
bot robot vehicles steered in real dense
tissue a pig's eye in this case usually
these tiny vehicles never gave through
artificial demonstrational biological
liquids not real tissue the bots were
made out of iron spirals that would swim
under the presence of a magnet the trick
and the breakthrough was a special
double coating that allowed for the bust
to swim freely without damaging the
surrounding tissue the hope is to one
day incorporate a drug delivery system
into these devices so what is the vision
for this nano propeller what do you hope
it can do one day so the vision of these
nano propeller is that one day we will
load drug to the nano propeller and they
will carry these drugs and propel
through the reaches to the retina and
release drug very locally a targeted way
yeah so this is the first time that we
demonstrate it is possible to use these
nano robots to really penetrate real
biological tissues so what does the
future hold well there's a lot of
activity going on in this space
scientists at MIT have recently
developed optically power battery less
nanobots equipped with sensors able to
record and monitor chemicals like
enzymes and hormones the information can
then be downloaded and analyzed the
study has been hailed as a completely
new field of Robotics further to this
the California Institute of Technology
are throwing their hat in the ring
they're developing DNA robot toolkits
that are being created to allow medical
developers to use them and building more
capable DNA robots the device is made
from a single strand of DNA that can
autonomously navigate around a surface
pick up certain molecules and drop them
off at predetermined locations the
California team is the DNA nano bot to
successfully saw it six scattered
molecules into their pre assigned places
in 24 hours
adding more robots would reduce the time
needed to complete tasks luli cui an
assistant professor of bioengineering
comments quote it is my hope that other
researchers could use these principles
for exciting applications such as DNA
robot for synthesizing therapeutic
chemicals from its Acosta's jeep parts
in an artificial molecular factory
delivering a drug only when a specific
signal is given in blood streams or
cells or sorting out molecular
components in trash for recycling end
quote for some reason it reminds me of
open source development kits which other
programmers can build off this pattern
of building off others is very
commonplace wherever there's exponential
scientific development
okay so let's recap so we have DNA
robots they can detoxify blood other DNA
nano robots they can starve tumors
man-made nano robots that can swim
through dense tissue tiny nano robots
that Consensus chemical environment
within a body and relay that information
to medical professionals and a DNA
nanorobot development kit if we're to
compare the current situation to the
historical progress of computers this
would be like the 1960s when many
computers were raining they were hard to
use limited to research groups not quite
a revolution but they showed great
promise all this could be like the
Internet of the 1980s where online
communities existed but it was before
the web and worse still when people were
figuring out how the
was all going to work although it's
early in its lifecycle the progress of
nano bust is moving rapidly maybe in 10
to 15 years nanobots will become
commonplace addition to the field of
biotech that is if a meaningful way to
reduce the future cost is found so that
just about wraps up our look at nano
robots let me know what you think in the
comment section below so thanks for
watching this has been - go go you've
been watching cold fusion if you've just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe I'm sure you'll find some
interesting stuff around here thanks for
watching and I'll see you again soon for
the next video
cheers guys
[Music]